the incident was filmed from several
angles on different cameras by the
migrants themselves they're firing
directly at us the man says the language
is Farsi he's Iranian the field is just
on the Turkish side of the border with
Greece you can see the fence line in
Greece beyond six men were hit three in
the leg one in the groin one in the
chest and one in the head they are from
Afghanistan Pakistan and Iran they were
rushed back from the fence to Turkish
ambulances and away to hospital where we
arrived a few hours later to this she is
the wife of a man called Gulzar he was
the one hit in the chest
she's just identified his body in the
morgue all we know of their story is
that they had traveled from Pakistan
heading for Europe drawn to the border
at the weekend when Turkey said it was
open now he's dead and Greece and Turkey
are blaming each other for the shooting
as we were invited into the hospital by
officials from the Turkish government
they released a statement saying it was
the Greek police who fired on the
migrants to see the injured they're very
very keen that we do we were shown a
picture of a bullet they said had been
removed from one of the men in the ward
with officials present they explained
what had happened we threw stones at
them as they didn't open the border then
they fired tear gas because the tear gas
wasn't effective they got out rifles and
shot us with them outside we met a man
who
with Gulzar when he was shot there came
a demon and the the shooting came from
the other side is that what he's saying
vigilantes on the Greek side then or the
Greek border guards the Greek government
is crying fake news Shimura there won't
be I note that the Turkish side
constructs and disseminates fake news
against our country yeah one more fake
news was spread today about alleged
injured from Greek fire I categorically
deny it
what now though for her mark stone sky
news on the Greece Turkey border